[Music]
all right let's go out to d-town dallas
texas and talk to melissa what's up
melissa
hi thank you so much for taking my call
today you got it what's up um
i have an issue with a um a used car
that i just purchased
less than 30 days ago
and i believe i've been scammed by the
dealership
you know as far as the condition of the
car
when i purchased it
due to a
multi-point inspection that they gave me
that
is inaccurate
in relation to what i found out that's
actually happening to the car
and so
i'm wondering if
i
can return it or if i
you know should request to get help with
the repairs
or if i should just kind of
you know
accept just i don't know i don't i hate
to say responsibility but
accept what has happened and then just
kind of do what i can to get things
fixed on it
so what does the car need repaired
um so
it needs um two front axles in the front
um it has a transmission leak there's
some type of
ring or seal that needs to correct that
it needs rotors and brake pads
and none of this was in the inspection
no was this a reputable dealer it was
just on the side of the road where'd you
get this car
no this was a reputable
bigger dealership have you contacted
them
i have
and they told me
that um
of course they said it says there's no
warranty but there was no sticker on the
car that you know usually i didn't even
realize that until recently when i
bought it there was no sticker or
anything and there's no paperwork that
says that so
but um
also they said well we'll just you know
take care of the diagnostic on the car
but we're not doing anything else beyond
that here's what i would do i would take
it first i would go get it um a
second inspection even if i got to pay
for it okay i would go get another
mechanic that you trust to take their
step-by-step inspection and go through
it and have them sign off on each one of
these things okay
a certified mechanic and just
you're frustrated right now and you're
part
pissed off at them and you're part
kicking yourself and
it's good to get a professional expert
on all these little points okay because
it may narrow down to actually you don't
need this you'll need this you need two
things or they may look at you and say
i'm so sorry you got taken advantage of
okay
so melissa i answered these questions um
you know how i would respond if i was in
your shoes and what i would do is go to
the dealership in person and ask for the
sales manager not the sales person the
sales manager because they can actually
do something about it and be kind and
appeal at a human level and say hey i'm
looking for a fair solution to this
problem here's what happened this is my
starting point have you tried that
i
i would say this i have been talking
directly to the sales manager
dude i think maybe three times so far
and he's the one who's saying we're not
going to we're going up we're going to
find the vp of the dealership we're
going to go to the next level up but i
want you to take that other i want you
to take that other inspection with you
okay so that you is it's not just
feelings and opinions it's data that's
exactly right which john loves facts
over feelings
so if you go to the vp if you go to the
higher level of management and they
still do nothing that's when we go all
right i didn't want to play hardball but
we're doing it you're going to contact
the consumer financial protection bureau
you can contact the ftc the federal
trade commission the attorney general
you can turn to social media and that is
going to light a fire under their butts
to do something about this problem i
guarantee it
okay if they if they winked over a
crummy car right they pulled one over on
you
there is um
there is like a lesson learned right i'm
gonna always anytime i get a car i'm
gonna take it to a certified mechanic
that's not a part of the dealership to
have like these are things you learn as
you go
dave calls them stupid texts right like
it just is what it is
i'm concerned that
you were lied to you were handed a piece
of paper that said this thing has been
certified and if it has then there's a
mechanic in that facility that has a
certification number that's signed off
on this thing
and if it's traced back to that
particular mechanic then they're going
to lose their their certification
license okay
okay and so i i want to get i really a
third party to look at it for and then
and then what george said and by the way
go in there with kindness and directness
and data
um if you go in yelling and screaming
and kicking like i would go on i feel
like doing right now on your behalf um
people are gonna send me away is that
fair
yeah yeah totally because yeah i think
they
somehow i feel like they knew or they
didn't really look at this car
you know and they just put it on the lot
and
i don't think that's right they may have
for them to tell me okay
yeah no if they handed you a piece of
paper that said hey it's been certified
it's all good we've passed our
inspection then
that's that's dishonest business right
um they lied to you and they took
advantage of you and um
hopefully we can get this worked out if
they can't
and ultimately you exhaust these calls
like that george gave you and nothing
there's nothing to come of it
exhale it sucks it is what it is then
we're gonna get this thing paid off
we're gonna get it repaired or we're
gonna get sold whatever and then we're
just gonna have learned for next time
carrying around the anger and the
frustration and the rage does not solve
any of these problems moving forward
it's become frustrating um george like
these things make me so mad i know i i'm
one of my biggest pet peeves is like
consumer
issues like this where it just makes
your blood boil and i'm not i'm not a
fan of the like the customer is always
right they're not sometimes you got to
fire your customers because they're
crazy but there is a level that i want
to help people stand up for themselves
and realize they have options a lot of
people just go well either i eat it or i
have to go in there kicking and
screaming there's a different option you
can go in with kindness you can do a
step-by-step approach and then ramp it
up over time and go all right i have to
go to social media i'm going to have to
report it to the ftc
whoever attorney that because y'all
clearly exactly honest with me yeah but
oftentimes i found that just taking that
first step being a real person with the
sales manager being a little bit of a
squeaky wheel with the vp going listen
man you guys
i've had a great experience other than
this yeah and i would hate for that to
harness that me for have to talk to my
friends and tell them to stay away from
this dealership because of how they
treated their customers and for me to
have to go to the ft i don't want to go
down this path let's just make it right
i'm not asking for a lot i'm not asking
for a free car i'm just asking for you
to make these repairs and i'll be on my
way and i i bought a car several months
ago and
from a dealer here in town and it was
such a
negative dishonest experience at the
very end with the last little gotcha i
had my kids with me were we were coming
back i mean it was a whole thing but i
looked at the salesman and said
i hope this feels good congratulations
um you got me you got me
and um
i can tell you not a single person and
i'm not gonna be ugly i'm gonna be rude
i'm gonna take my kids i'm gonna take
this thing this car and we're gonna go
we will never do business here again and
if anyone says hey i'm gonna i'm gonna
let them know right with kindness and
respect
um and it wasn't worth
wasn't worth the the lack of it but
you're too classy to name drop them on
air and i respect that nope not gonna do
that